all right michael i've got one for you
i'm an anesthesia provider in a blue
state that does gender affirmation
surgeries yes my institution cuts
perfectly functioning body parts off
people
with underdeveloped prefrontal cortexes
and
mental illnesses
my question is is how do i conduct
myself in an atmosphere i do not want to
be in
i love what i do
this is only a sliver
of
what i do as an anesthesia provider but
i have a very difficult time in the
operating room surrounded by people who
were given the title of doctor although
they
fail on
maintaining objective reality and truth
and doing this and they consistently
call girls boys and boys girls
give me some advice
anything will help thanks
really tough problem i don't think you
necessarily need to quit your job
but
i
i would not be able to participate in
those kinds of surgeries so you say it
doesn't happen frequently maybe but
when when little kids come in and
they're psycho parents and these sick
doctors decide to put them under and
then chop off their body parts
you might be called in to provide the
anesthesia
if i were you i would not be able to do
that i i don't i
i think it would probably disturb your
sleep at night i think your conscience
will probably bother you because of that
i would i would not participate there
are different different degrees to which
people participate in evil there are
really indirect ways
a really indirect way that one could
participate in evil is by going over and
eating a girl scout cookie at a friend's
house and the girl scout cookie funds
the girl scouts organization of america
and some chapters of a girl scouts
organization used to partner with
planned parenthood and so
as a result you're basically performing
an abortion when you eat your friend's
cookie right well there is a there is a
remote participation with evil there
perhaps but it's not it's not a very
direct one at a certain point you can't
really operate in the world if depending
on how removed you become from this the
very fact that you and i pay taxes means
that we are
funding planned parenthood
just to stick on that same example so
there are
there are
there is nuance when we're talking about
a very very remote participation with
evil you're not you're not morally
required to participate with evil in in
any way certainly not but it's it's a
different situation than when we're
talking about a direct participation
with an evil act so i would i would i
would say no to that
and i i like to think that your
your superiors would accommodate that i
i know some people who work in the
medical field who say they they're not
going to do that kind of thing
specifically on transgender surgeries
the people that i know have who have who
have voiced those concerns have been
accommodated your mileage may vary and
you might need to go to a different
health care center but that's that's the
way i would parse the issue i'm so glad
you like that clip now
ring
subscribe
ding dong click that bell make sure you
get the notifications for the michael
knowles show then here's what i need you
to do i need you to copy this link and
then just text it and email it to all of
your friends there are people still in
america today around the world today who
don't listen to the michael knowles show
and i feel very sorry for those people
so make sure you send it around get
those notifications we will see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you